[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Hi,
I'm Maya Kaczorowski,
and I'm here at KubeCon
EU in Copenhagen
walking the show floor.
And here with JFrog.
Hi.
RAJ PANCHAPAKESAN: Hi, I'm Raj.
I'm with JFrog and I take
care of technology alliances
and partnerships, and I take
care of the Google partnership
for the last year or so.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: That's great.
Raj, how does JFrog
work with GKE?
RAJ PANCHAPAKESAN: So we have
been very closely tied with GKE
and we have all of our
instances running on GKE.
Our Artifactory is provided
as a product on GKE.
And we also are providing
the Kubernetes registry now
as part of our contribution
to the community.
And this is something
which we have been involved
in the last couple of years as
part of the development of many
of the Kubernetes registry
as a de facto registry
for implementing
Kubernetes clusters.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: That's great.
So if a customer wants to use
JFrog, it's super easy for them
to go find it.
And what they do?
RAJ PANCHAPAKESAN: Absolutely.
It's basically available
on GCP as a SAS offering.
And we also support
the Grafeas platform.
And that is the
most important part
because our products
are Grafeas API,
and the Xray product
has a Grafeas API
which works seamlessly
with the Grafeas platform.
And we also are very closely
working with Orbitera.
This is our test platform.
If anybody wants to take a
test drive on JFrog products--
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
They can use Orbitera.
RAJ PANCHAPAKESAN:
They can use Orbitera,
and we provide a free
instance on Orbitera,
which there is a set up there
where people can go in and play
with JFrog products and also
experience how GCP works.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Got it.
So if I want to test it
out, go check out Orbitera?
RAJ PANCHAPAKESAN: Yes.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Anything else
about the Google partnership
with JFrog you want to touch on?
RAJ PANCHAPAKESAN: Yeah.
I mean Google is one of
our premier partners,
and we have been
working very closely
on Grafeas, on Kubernetes
as a contributor,
and also now Helm repository.
So Helm is something which we
have been using very closely.
And that is now
available on GCP as well.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI:
Thank you so much, Raj.
RAJ PANCHAPAKESAN: All right.
Thank you.
MAYA KACZOROWSKI: Thanks.
And thanks, all, for
joining us keep KubeCon EU.
Have a good one.
[MUSIC PLAYING]